da haben wir viele Themen heute sprechen
wir darüber mit Prof Klaus zerstör
Virologe und Epidemiologe hallo Herr
schönen guten Tag
weniger Reisewarnungen nun damit auch
das offizielle goat zum Reisen macht das
Sinn aus ihrer Sicht
ja das politische Ziel hier hat ja Herr
Spahn erläutert man möchte sowohl die
absoluten als auch die relativen Anteil
an Fällen reduzieren also absolut an
insgesamt corona-infektionen und dann
die Delta Variante so wenig wie möglich
im relativen Anteil haben aus der
epidemiologischen virologischen
Perspektive im Vergleich auch zu dem
langzeitziel macht das für mich nicht so
den ganz großen Sinn warum wir haben
eine Inzidenz gegenwärtig um 5 und um
sechs das heißt also wir sind ungefähr
zehnmal ja 15 mal 20 mal niedriger in
der Inzidenz als im Winter die Zahlen
sind weiterhin im Sinkflug auf den
Intensivstationen liegen eigentlich nur
noch die langzeitfälle es kommen ganz in
der vereinzelt neue Fälle hinzu die
hospitalisierungsrate ist gering die
Delta Variante macht ungefähr 20% im
Durchschnitt gibt große Schwankungen in
den Bundesländern aus wenn die
Verdopplungszeit hier tatsächlich bei
einer Woche oder zehn Tagen damit heißt
das dass wenn jetzt 20 Prozent da
ausmacht dann sind das in einer Woche 40
und in zwei Wochen 80 Prozent also dass
diese Variante nun übernimmt daran
können auch die reiserückkehrer wenn wir
sie kontrollieren oder nicht
kontrollieren keinen Unterschied mehr
machen
habe und auch von Ihnen gelesen habe
dann ist es doch bei der Delta Variante
offenbar so dass es zwar mehr Fälle gibt
sie aber weniger schlimm ist zumindest
in den Auswirkungen wo ist aus ihrer
Sicht das Problem der delta-variante
ja die Welt dabei haben sie hat
eigentlich kein Problem wir konstruieren
glaube ich ein Problem um die Variante
herum das war bei der Alpha Variante ja
auch schon es ist natürlich auch
erschreckend für viele zu sehen dass ein
irgendwie neu zumindest was den Namen
betrifft neues Virus auftaucht aber man
muss immer wieder sagen dasselbe Virus
gelbe Pandemie die selben
Bekämpfungsmaßnahmen helfen auch die
Impfung schreitet ja auch noch voran die
Saisonalität hat ja nun für den letzten
auch der nicht dann glauben wollte im
Winter ein dramatischen Effekt also ich
kann auch nicht richtig verstehen woher
die ganzen Warnungen kommen es ist
natürlich so zeitgleich mit dem
auftretender Delta Variante in Europa
neben die Fälle in Indien in Indonesien
auch in Afrika zu das hat mehr was mit
einem nachhole Effekt zu tun die der
Region waren weitestgehend ausgespart in
der letzten Zeit man hat sich auch
relativ unvernünftig Verhalten in Indien
die großen Feste die stattgefunden haben
ohne Vorkehrungsmaßnahmen die
einem dort zu und nimmt in England zu
jetzt kommt die nach Deutschland aber es
ist ja nicht rational zu sehen zu singen
jetzt dass die Variante dass die
Gesamtzahl der Fälle im Sinkflug ist und
gleichzeitig schiebt man ja Delta
Variante so eine schlimme Rolle dazu das
muss ich jetzt mal verstehen
entschuldigen Sie also wenn ich ihnen
zuhören auch den Experten also wenn ich
weiß dass heute stand heute knapp ein
Drittel etwas über ein Drittel der
Deutschen schon zweifach geimpft ist und
mehr als die Hälfte einfach geimpft ist
wenn ich der Weltgesundheitsorganisation
zuhöre für die sie ja 15 Jahre lang bis
2007 gearbeitet haben die heute noch mal
davor warnt dass es eine neue
corona-welle in Europa geben könnte dann
sind das unterschiedlichste gegenläufige
Aussagen können Sie mich noch mal
aufklären haben wir nun ein großes
Risiko dass wir in den nächsten Wochen
in den nächsten Monaten wieder in eine
große
corona-dilemma schlittern oder nicht
ja das ist das der dass man nicht
auseinander hält zwischen vielen Fällen
und hoher Krankheitslast wird
tatsächlich wird es im Herbst Fehler
mehr Fälle geben es wird eine
winterwelle geben der leichte aber die
wird sich auf zwei Ebenen unterscheiden
erstens werden nicht mehr so viel
schwere Erkrankungen auftreten weil dann
ja hoffentlich die über 50-jährige
geimpft sind zum Großteil zumindestens
ja und da kommt 99% der Todesfälle vor
da kommen die Intensivstation Belegung
vor die Hospitalisierung dieser Teil
wird viel viel weniger dramatisch
ausfallen aber natürlich sind noch 20
Millionen 30 Millionen Deutsche auch
noch ungeimpft bzw haben noch keine
natürliche Immunität und die werden
erkranken aber die Krankheit klassische
viel geringer sein also man muss ja
auseinander halten Delta Variante kommt
es werden sich auch mit dieser Variante
viele Menschen infizieren zum Glück sind
die älteren dann hoffentlich alle
geimpft dadurch weniger schwere
Erkrankung geringere Krankheitslast aber
auch die jüngeren kennen schon nach
Erkrankungen das wird passieren jetzt im
Herbst habe ich gerade verstanden sehr
gut zwei Fragen habe ich noch das eine
ist vor einem Jahr haben Familien in
dieser corona-zeit ja sehr stark
gelitten spricht aus ihrer Sicht
irgendetwas gegen die komplette Öffnung
von Schulen und Kitas nach den
Sommerferien
also ich glaube alle Personen die eine
impfangebot angenommen haben das getan
haben gibt es für mich als
epidemiologisch biologisch und
vielleicht auch restliche rechtlicher
Sicht keinen Grund mehr
ja aber die Kinder über 12 können sich
impfen lassen wenn es die Eltern wollen
und da muss man sehen wie
verhältnismäßig ist das in Deutschland
sind zwischen im Alter zwischen 12 und
16 Jahren gab es keine Todesfälle bei
Kindern ich glaube zwei mit sehr starken
Vorbelastungen palliativer Betreuung
also es gab keine Todesfälle in der
Altersgruppe 12 bis 16 und es gab
Hospitalisierung aber das sind alles
restitute gewesen also vollständige
Lesung oder
Genesung die sehr nah dran waren also
hier muss man entscheiden ist es
tatsächlich notwendig und wichtig und
hat die STIKO ja ihre Meinung gesagt
dass sich die Kinder über 12 bis 16
insgesamt weil ja auch die Impfung ein
Risiko darstellt und dieses Risiko für
die Impfung ist gegenwärtig höher
eingeschätzt als für eine Infektion
Kinder unter 12 Jahren gibt es auch sehr
gute Daten vom Kollegen Werner und
seinem großen Netzwerk für der
Intensivstation bei Kindern die Macht
die
Erkrankung relativ wenig also Impfung ja
ich destilliere daraus zerstört dass sie
tatsächlich also sagen würden Kinder und
es spricht nichts dagegen dass nach den
Sommerferien weiter alle dann
tatsächlich auch in Präsenz kommen
können letzter Punkt noch gleichzeitig
sehen wir dann aber nächste Woche im
Halbfinale und im Finale der Fußball
Europameisterschaft des europäischen
Fußballverbandes UEFA 60.000 Zuschauer
im Wembley Stadion in London gute Idee
aus ihrer Sicht
ja also ich habe für die UEFA selbst die
Risikoberechnung gemacht in München also
wie hoch ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass
in München noch jemand ansteckt sie
Wahrscheinlichkeit war das in
Flugzeugabsturz war höher als dass sich
dort jemand tödlich infizieren wird in
München das waren 14.500 Zuschauer
wemble 60.000 das ist natürlich schon
eine andere Größenordnung wenn nur
geimpfte hineinkommen nur negativ
getestete dann ist das Risiko sicherlich
viel geringer aber ich hätte von
Massenveranstaltungen der Größenordnung
mit der Dichte vielleicht da wäre schon
ein bisschen vor sich hier gewesen aber
14.500 wie in München mit Abständen da
ist das Risiko sicherlich viel geringer
bei 60.000 sicherlich deutlich höher
Professor Klaus Stöhr Virologe und
Epidemiologe vielen Dank für das
Gespräch hierbei Phoenix
ich bedanke mich bei Ihnen